this next story is sponsored by
intermountain healthcare and it's a tear
jerker it's about the gift of friendship
and life take a look
hi my name is rakita sanchez
i work for a las vegas police department
and i've been employed for 13 years
and i'm christina martinez and i've been
employed by the las vegas police officer
for seven years when i was 22 years old
i was diagnosed with lupus a rare form
i was told that i would probably not
make it to my 23rd birthday
i am now 37. at one point my kidneys
completely failed
they were amazed that i even walked into
the hospital because my kidney function
was below 5
the doctors told me
that i would need to start dialysis and
she was actually in the room that day
and she said i'll give her a kidney i
was like what do i need to do where do i
start it's just amazing when people step
forward and want to help another person
like that as a transplant kidney doctor
we work with both patients with kidney
failure that need a kidney transplant
and make sure that they're healthy
enough to undergo the procedure we also
evaluate
kidney donors living kidney donors and
ensure that they're healthy enough and
that it's safe for them to be a kidney
donor so that's how i was involved in
both
requita's care and
christina as a living kidney donor
we went in for surgery they put you out
immediately you feel no pain no
anxiousness anything
when you come out of
the surgery they monitor you
for a little while just to make sure
that you're you're doing good and you're
responding like you're supposed to and
then you go into the recovery room
and then another phenomenal doctor that
prescribes all your medicines
make sure that you have the right dosage
and the right medication that is good
for you unfortunately every day 11 or 12
people die waiting for a kidney
transplant
living kidney donation offers really
quite a bit of hope for for these
patients and is really life changing for
them
living kidney donation allows us to
oftentimes do the transplant sooner
and the outcomes are usually better than
compared to a deceased donor and now i
take
a few medications in the morning and a
few at night and i can do everything
with my kids
and they see a happy healthier
more energized mom it's really a
life-changing event for the recipient
it tends to double their life expectancy
and usually they have a much improved
quality of life if not a near normal
life the thought of
my kidney making her feel amazing and
look so much better and healthy and to
be there for her family for
years and years and years to come
that's you know for me someone asked me
do i feel like i did before
i was sick
which has been 15 years so
my whole adult life
i've had this illness
and i don't know what that felt like but
it's hard
i feel great
thank you to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring that segment for more
information on the benefits of living
donor transplants and the national
kidney registry head to registerme.org